こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんジャニーズの
伝説の男
山田涼介君をご存知でしょうかここ僕の
最近引っ越した東京のお家なんですけども
初めてのゲスト
この方ですどうぞ
どうも
山田ですかっこいい
いやようこそそんなやつじゃないよろしく
お願いしますよろしくお願いします最近
引っ越しました
[音楽]
本当あったことなかったんですよねなかっ
たですね
[音楽]
実は同級生なんですみたいな感じですよ
そうですね
[音楽]
じゃあちょっとこの動画を機会にやめよう
ぜやめようぜ
タメ語で分かった行こう行こうよろしくお
願いします今日は何をするんですかさっき
Twitterでですね
山田涼介とはじめしたとの質問募集して
おきましたありがとうございます
とりあえずちょっとそれも色々聞きつつ
ちょっと船とヤマトさんゲームも好きって
いうことも聞いてるんでちょっと一緒に
ゲームとかで遊べると
仲良くなってくださいよろしくお願いし
ます
[音楽]
よ
ね見
られる仕事だとなんかこうそこの見られ
てるエネルギーでなんか分からないけど
若くいられない結構やってます
美容系とか
脱毛ぐらいのあ脱毛か脱毛はね俺したこと
ない
えっけな毛がない
すね毛に山芋ぐらいの毛が生えてるなんで
も見てくださいもうトレンドにとってます
えちょっと2人で答えていけそうなのを
期待したいと思いますちょっと僕に来て
ました
初めて社長さんの思う山田涼介さんの一番
かっこいいところと一番可愛いと思う
ところは何ですかとドラマの撮影現場とか
全体になるんですけどもなんかすごいオン
になった時めっちゃかっこいいなと思い
ます
なんかそんなに
意識してないけど結構やっぱ違いますよ
違う撮影前はなんか今日優しそうな感じだ
けど
入った時なんかキリッとしてる感じがする
あと
顔が可愛いと思います
すいませんまだ本当出会いたてなので
あんまりわかんないと思うんですけどもお
互いに好きなところ行ってくださいあー何
だろう人がやらないこと
を制してやろうって思うそこの勇気
クリエイターとしてというか
尊敬してますありがとうございます結構
チャレンジングなことも他にも色々悩ん
でるじゃないですかそこをなんかこう開拓
してってる感じの
姿勢っていうのがやっぱり同い年なかなか
できることじゃないなと思いながらいつも
思ってます
ありがとうございます本当に
山田くんの好きなところは
富山県出身で
田舎に住んでるそこら辺の
男の子だったからもうなんかクモの目の
存在というかね
世の中にこんなかっこいい人もいるんだ
なあと思ってクラスの女子が山田君の話
知ってる記憶もある昔から活躍し続けて今
も最前線で活躍されてるのが僕すごいなっ
て思います
でもなんかこう時代が変わる中でやっぱり
こうYouTuber
逆にこう
芸能僕らもそうでしたけど
YouTubeに参入させていただく
みたいな感じで
先輩なんですよ
そんなことないですねお互いがお互いに
何者ねだりじゃないのなんかこう
リスペクトし合う部分がなんかいいやと
関係が築けているなっていうのはなんか
どっちもやらせてもらうことで
YouTubeをやってる人たちの凄さ
みたいなのがすごく感じですね
ありがとうございます2人の接点は
接点で言うとね今回
親愛なる僕で撮影コメントという動画で
朝がこうはじめしゃちょーは友達
役でえーみたいなそこで初めて設定ができ
たというか
イレギュラはイレギュラーですね
イレギュラーもうお互いにこう
YouTubeやってるからなんか
YouTubeでまず知り合いそうなの
ドラマで
すっ飛ばしてね
出会うという逆にどうだったのそのドラム
のファンが来ましたみたいな
いやもうめっちゃ嬉しかったんですけど
正直
山田君に会えるっていう気持ちがちょっと
言うけどね
嬉しいわそれは嬉しいあと接点といえば
もうゲーム好きでゲーム大好き最近何か
やってますよね
僕は
FXを主にやってるんですけど
Splatoonの
ちょこっと触ったりとか
スプラトゥーンやりましょうおぜひぜひ
めっちゃ減ってますよ
銃使えなくてもうローラーしか言って
くださいってきてるんですけど
山田君怪我させるわけにいかないと
ちょっとやめときます
怪我しても怪我しちゃうね
何させてんだ2人で可愛いポーズして
ください
山田くん可愛い子をする意味しないのあ
じゃあ初めに教えていいですかえあるんす
か
すっげー中途半端に流行ったヤマハとか
ヤマハートで生まれたちょっとぜひ教えて
いただけると唇の下で
これだけです
はいそれをじゃあ
わかりますか
せーの
ありがとうございますこちらこそ
使っていこう2人で全力キメ顔まで321
ねかっこいいから
ていうか
これはちょっと俺も聞いてみたいな今後
YouTubeでの共演はありますかあー
もうこれぜひですけどねマジですか何この
結構
うちの
後輩からをしていただいてますね美少年
うんとコラボしてそこから仲良くなって
たまにね一緒にサラダとか行ってるはじめ
山田君お姫様抱っこしてくださいいける
ちょっと
重いよいやいやいけるの
[音楽]
軽い
安心感
[音楽]
力持ちっすね
結構やってたもんね一時期めっちゃ筋トレ
やってた見てこの彼氏彼女のなんかサイズ
感の違うあーいい質問がありましたあり
ましたまさか旅行とか好き
2人で旅行行くならどこ行きますかえ
海外の前に
海外もありますよ僕
色々で結果ハワイが一番好きなんですよ
最近行ってきた方が
[音楽]
めっちゃ良かったです
行きましょういつからお互いを認知し
たって言ってます俺は
デビューぐらいから
平成ジャンプという存在をしたりその中で
山田涼介と言いました俺はマジかこれ
めっちゃ早かったですよ僕は逆に
気になりますいつから準備したぞという
存在を知ってたからいやもうなんか気づい
たら日常にいたというか
きっかけが何の動画かとかをもう分から
ないぐらい僕らの生活の中にはじめしゃ
ちょーが現れない
そうなんだなんかねそんなデビュー作と
いうかねドカーンってきたのはあんまなく
て積み重ねで
気づいたのは
自分がこれきっかけで来たなっていうのも
ないんだあんまりピントは
本当にそうだらだらだらだらと1000万
超えた
とんでもない化け物たい焼きはどこから
食べますか
気になって何だろう
気になってるよ
僕尻尾です
まあ俺頭ですわあー仲良くなれないな
こんな
質問するから胸派ですかそれとも尻派です
か
僕は
足です
足か僕は
両方ですもう最高
じゃんけんしてください
じゃんけんぽい
はいというわけで皆さんたくさん質問
ありがとうございました
山田君ってスマブラとかする
うん見ればあの
配信とかでもそのあそうなんですか
強いですか
[音楽]
遊びに行ったからちょっとゲームとか
やりましょうか
やろうかいただきます
お願いします
居たくない
えっ
Rでガードでしょ
RでガードOKですかOKじゃあ
ゲームはうまいんだよな
結構積極的に
攻撃をちょっと待ってくださいね
なんだ今の
ちょっと待ってやばい
やめろ
[音楽]
おいおい
始めよう
[拍手]
はじめやめてくれ
ちゃんと強い
[音楽]
まずい
なんで
よし
ちょっと待ってよ
ちゃんと緊急会議してくるね
緊急回避って何
あこれはきつ
い
よしよしよしよしよしあと1期
ちゃんと
動くなぁ
ちょっと待ってよ
まずいな
[音楽]
んですかそれ
危ねえ
今の
まずいありがとう
ございます
ちゃんと強い
全然やってないですねやってなくて
そこそこ最初押されてたから
本当うん
キングクルールとかなんか
イメージなんだけどそうね結構パワー
タイプで一番
得意なのがネス
強そう
初めはどれぐらい強いのレベルで言うと
だからYouTuberの中では
強い方
全然
強い人たくさんいるからあちょっと待って
よね
ちょっと待ってねなるほどそういうことし
ちゃうなるほどちょっと
待ってくださいね
ちょっと待って
普通に押されてるんだけど
あちょ待って
そのお腹のね
これか
あーなんかダメなんだね飛んだらね
飛んだらダメなんだね
緊急回避は普通に入れてくる
[音楽]
まずいよはいよーしよしよしあーちょっと
飛んじゃう
強いよ
やばい
それ使わない
そろそろやばいな
ちょっと待ってあ大丈夫
おいなんだこのデブ
強ですいや素晴らしいやっぱ強いですね
いやいやこれはでも
強くなって帰ってきますよちょっとお願い
します
[音楽]
お疲れ様でしたありがとうございました
楽しかった
仲良くなりました
[音楽]
なんかその人見知りっていうのもなんか
聞いててちょっとなんか寝てる部分が多い
なと思ってなんか最初に出会った時の空気
感一緒だと
確かになります
すごい似てて
親近感を感じると仲良くなれたらいいなと
思いますまたそのくれますか
お願いしますありがとうございます
連絡先聞いてもいいですか
ちょっと
待ってお互い気づいたと思うんですけど
敬語があった武器でないんですけど
ちょっとまだ仲良くなれる余地があると
思うんでね
よろしくお願いしますはいというわけで
なぜ今日こうやって山田くんと一緒に動画
を撮れたかお家に遊びに来てくれたかと
いうとですねドラマ信頼になる僕撮影を
込めてはきっかけになっておりますはい
ありがとうございます本当にね
[音楽]
こうやってYouTubeでしょ
ほんと変わった繋がり方でお会いできまし
た
僕はこうねドラマとか映画とかねなかなか
[音楽]
僕はないとでもしかしたらこれ今後さこれ
をきっかけにさあ
[音楽]
皆さんお待ちしておりますそのね10
月5日ですかね
のでぜひぜひ見ていただければなとそこに
多分結構ねそう一緒に
[音楽]
頼りますよね
初代が15分拡大で結構長くやるので
ぜひ見てみてくださいこれ見逃してしまっ
てもあのTVerとFODで
見る日見逃しちゃったよって方はそっち見
てくださいお願いしますというわけでは
またはいどういうドラマなんですかどう
いうドラマもうね見ておー
あのね一言でほんと説明するのが難しいん
ですけど
毎週水曜の夜10時が多分みんな楽しみに
なるとドラマになってことだと思います
一緒にこう誰が
犯人なのか一体何かどうなってるんだろう
一緒に推理しながら楽しめる夜になると
思うのでぜひぜひ一緒に頭を抱えながら
楽しみにしてていただければなという風に
思います見ててくださいよねお願いします
また
遊びに来てねスマブラでリベンジ待って
ますマチってボコボですよね次ほんと
頑張ろうね
お邪魔する形になるのかな強くなったと
思います
[音楽]
ぜひ
ありがとうございました
山田さんでした
[音楽]